-We're back with my family.
One more thing about
the engagement.
Mom gave you her ring
to propose with.
-Yeah.
-To McKenzie.
But, Dad,
this had been your mom's ring.
-It was my mother's ring.
And when Hillary and I
got married, we were 22.
I was going to grad school.
She was hoping for a job.
We had no money.
And I said to my mother,
"Hey, can I have that ring?
I'm going to get married."
And my mother said,
"I'll give it to you when
you've been married 10 years."
And when we were married
10 years, I got it.
But we didn't have to wait
to give it to Josh.
-Yeah.
-It's very nice that
she had so much faith in Mom.
-She did.
She said I had really good teeth
and I had strong bones.
[ Laughter ]
-Did she say that
at 22 or at 32?
She was like, "We got to see
if these bones hold up."
-She thought if we had to farm
for a living, we'd be okay.
-Yeah. No. It's very --
-She said she was a strong girl.
-Well, the Swedish background,
you know.
-Yeah, but that is
how you describe a horse.
[ Laughter ]
A beautiful coat.
-Yeah.
She had good withers.